Please welcome from Hospital for Special Surgery
Chief Digital and Technology
Officer Ashish Barad. [Music]
Hello everybody. Uh so I am Dr. Ashish Barad. I'm
a practicing physician for roughly 20 years now.
Um, and um, you know, wi with that being said,
the the work we're doing with Palunteer um,
is is really exceptional. I can't wait to
to dive in uh, from that perspective. Um,
there's an interesting fact that I want to
open with that you may not know. So, uh, since
I started practice roughly 20 years ago now, uh,
physician productivity has dropped roughly 13%.
So just think about that for a second. Nursing
even more significant, right? So I did a time
study recently. Our nurses spend a roughly 20%
of their shift with um their uh patients. That's
a lot of hours, a lot of time on paperwork,
administrative tasks. So um we um we are taking
that on and that's and I want to make a very
significant portion of that is after we digitized
everything in healthcare. So although there's
still foxes do exist in healthcare um we um
have digitized everything and yet productivity has
dropped 13%. So our our partnership with Palunteer
is really focused on giving that time back so our
front lines can spend time with their patients
which is what they went to nursing medical school
to do. So before we dive in, um I do want to make
sure that many of you may not know what HSS stands
for. It's a hospital for special surgery. We're in
New York. Uh and it really is the premier
destination for muscularkeeletal health,
right? Um and you can read the stats. Uh we have
many of them. We're very proud of them. Um but
I'll I'll leave you with this just as far as the
the hospital goes. uh during the NBA playoffs uh
when your Achilles tendons pop, you come to HSS.
So, uh it is absolutely the place to be. So,
uh you know, I'm going to dive into a demo uh to
show you something u different that we're doing
now. And I know you heard a lot about appeals
with Main Health. Uh so I won't spend as much time
um on this slide but I do want to say that at the
beginning of this year we partnered with Palunteer
uh and we decided to take on that same journey
of automating insurance appeals um and uh and
as a physician appeals authorizations insurance is
the bane of your existence oftent times. Um and we
really took that on end to end and what we found
was 45 minutes of manual work by a lot of people
uh really just doing chart searching and typing
letters uh and taking on the insurance company
companies uh went down to 5 minutes and we did
that work in five weeks. We've been tapping
that for decades. Uh so in a simple fiveweek time
frame we were to automate all those and and what
we could get to to about 100 appeals per month to
insurance companies turned to a thousand appeals a
month and so it wasn't and and so the efficiency
was tremendous but I also want to make sure that
we don't just focus on efficiency the performance
of the AI was better than the people that were
doing it. So, um, and that time for those people
was given back to higher, uh, license work. Um,
and so, uh, it was a, it was a big win for us.
Appeals, you heard a lot about it a bit ago, so
I won't spend too much time on it, but I do want
to make sure you understand that roughly one in 10
appeals um, or uh, claims in healthcare claims
is denied by insurance companies. So we spend
a lot of our time and energy of manual labor,
our nurses, our doctors, our staff on really
working that um through. And so um if you really
uh think about the the fact that 17% of healthcare
uh or 17% of the GDP is on healthcare um a lot
of that has to do with this what's called waste
in medicine. This is an example of that waste.
It's really not in in any way helping a patient
uh a person get care. it's really just doing a lot
of uh manual labor and work uh paperwork. So to
automate that is very significant uh for people
getting care. Um so uh that's work that we've
already undertaken. We continue to do and um is
really significant. We expect a lot more things.
So, you know, having that win under our belt,
we we said, you know, that's wonderful and we've
automated a lot of the back end, but we haven't
really touched the patient and that's the center
of care that has drifted a bit in healthcare. We
spend so much time on the paperwork. We spend so
much time in the administrative work. We're not
spending as much time with the patient as I just
articulate at the beginning of this. So, how do
we get that time back? How do we really get the
patient back in to the center of the care? The
medical record that we've had in healthcare isn't
really focused on the patient as they go through
a journey. It's very siloed. And so when you show
up to a clinic, you go to the hospital, you get a
phone call, you may go to different specialists,
you might go to an imaging center, all that data
is not following really you along in a very,
you know, continuous way where the care teams are
are really reading off of one sheet of music. So
that's the work we're taking on with Balanteer
now. Uh so we started four weeks ago. Um and so
um really all that fragmentation of care um at
best it's a poor experience um at worst it's
critical details that get missed right leads to
poor outcomes um so we're building a patient card
is what we're calling it right so really just a
single sheet of music it's a single living summary
that travels with the person as they go through
their journey allergies medications care plans
what's next predictive uh and it's consistent
everywhere. So now you have clinicians, all
clinicians, surgeons, doctors, uh nurses, medical
assistants, patients, very important and payers,
right? They are part of your healthcare journey
all reading off the same page and that is not
possible in today's world. That data lives in
different places. So it's living as I said. So
the card updates right with real time in real
time. So orders, results and decisions change.
So I think at the beginning of this uh you heard
from American Airlines and in many ways I think
of running an O and I've done that before in
my past life um is like American Airlines,
right? We have crews, we have turnarounds,
we have clearances, we have equipment and the
occasional emergency, right? The difference, we
actually encourage sharp objects. So in this case,
uh we're seeing a patient that's not ready for
surgery uh as she needs a lifestyle medicine
referral. Right? So you see that the ontology
puts a flag there. Take a minute because right
we're if you just watched this demo you might
not really capture what's happening. Take a
minute think about Zoe. She's your mom. She's your
spouse. She's your sister. She's been hurting for
years. She needs a knee replacement. She lives
in pain every day. She finally got to the best
place on earth to get her knee done. And and the
surgeon said, "You need surgery. can't wait to be
painf free right now let's dive back into the
demo right because that person is waiting and
and can't wait to live painf free and so you see
AIP running it raises uh a flag there's a risk so
in seconds right it's assembling the relevant data
BMI tobacco use meds problem list it checks player
policy clinical criteria for medical necessity So
what you see now is because she's not yet cleared,
AIP is automatically compiling and submitting.
The agent is submitting as well the prior
authorization packet with the right documentation
and it's alerting the whole care team in real time
with a clear reason code and next steps. So what
you see is that she needs counseling for smoking
sessation and for weight right management. And
so that is a uh criteria that is both needed by
the insurance company and the right thing to do
for Zoe to ensure that she gets uh that in check
before she has surgery. Current state that is all
data that lives in different parts of the chart if
at all. Right? And that is something that really
if it gets picked up great oftentimes it doesn't
get picked up right and either again at best you
don't get paid for the surgery you're doing and
at worst at least the bad outcomes because that's
actually the right thing to do for the patient.
So here you see that she's moved through this
process and Zoe has moved into presurgical square
uh screening. her cardiac clearance is in and uh
the living patient card stays current across the
teams. The information that's being put in there,
the whole team's seeing it. And really what's
transformative about this agent that you're seeing
as far as next steps here is in a few clicks,
right? It's recommending same day discharge.
So now that she's had lifestyle medicine,
she actually qualifies for same day discharge.
She can go back to her own bed. she can sleep
and she can have her caregivers there doesn't need
to stay in the hospital right it's notifying the
whole teams that has a huge just like an airline
industry let's say has a huge implication on the
surgeon needs to know the nurses need to know the
clinicians the operators need to know uh insurance
u may need to know so again single pane of glass
it's messaging Zoe patient in the loop right that
is right now potentially nurse's job to remember
her to call Zoe and say, "Hey, you actually
qualify for same day discharge. We're going to
move up your surgery to be able to do that."
And that's a manual thing. And it takes time away
again from that 20% of time in the patient's room.
And we have a second customer in healthcare,
our physicians, right? So, and making sure
the surgeons in this case are aware of this move
and this recommendation and with consent offers
to move the surgery time. So, it's one source of
truth, coordinated actions, and zero swivel chair.
Hi, this is an automated call from the HSS
call center. Can you please confirm your
full name and date of birth? Hi, my name is
Zoe McMillan and I was born July 27th, 1961.
Hello, Miss McMillan. This is HSS scheduling
calling from HSS. I'm calling to inform you of
a change to your upcoming surgery schedule. So,
we're not going to play the whole recording for
the sake of time, but um it's right to have that
conversational AI to be able to guide having that
um source of truth to be able to guide
that conversation and to recommend same
day discharge. Um and if you listen to
the recording um which would say, well,
I can't do 11, can I do nine? Right? it's able to
accommodate that knowing the surgery schedule. Um,
so really really getting the patient back in the
loop and being able to have that shared decision-
making with patients that has oftentimes been
missing. So again, this is where we started with
a schedule with the red flag and this is where
we land, right? No red flags. Schedule optimized
not just for the patient but the clinicians,
the surgeons, the o texts. So no red flags,
everyone in the loop. Again, we stood this up in
four weeks. So, as far as speed to action, we're
just getting started on our journey. We're taking
the entire patient journey, right? From discovery,
ouch to recovery, right? And we're going to
use AI to orchestrate that. Very important.
We're not taking our frontline clinicians, our
doctors or nurses out of the loop. We're actually
elevating them, augmenting them to do what's
necessary that humans should do with humans.
AI is a really wonderful orchestrator. Things
get lost in the middle, right? And so that's
how we look at it. So our goal is simple,
right? We want our people with our patients
in their care journey and we want the agents to
do everything else. Thank you. [Applause] [Music]